a Chinese virologist called Li Ming Yan
is in hiding tonight after criticizing
the Chinese government's duplicitous
response to the Wuhan coronavirus here's
part of what she said to Fox News reason
I came to us a speak house I delivered
the message of the choose of cuvee 19 if
I tell it in Hong Kong the moment I
start to hear it I will be despaired and
killed no one can hear me so for this
purpose I like to go to us and tell the
truth of the origins of cuvee 92 the
world so met people understand how
terrible how dangerous it is
this is nothing about politics this
agency about visor all the human in the
world can survive for telling the truth
the doctor says she'll be quote
disappeared and killed this is the
government the NBA and so much of
corporate Americans so many of our
politicians suck up to one that murders
doctors for telling the truth this
doctor says Beijing is suppressing vital
information about the virus there are
many many patients they don't get
treatment on time and diagnosis on time
there is no protection for both doctors
and the patient and common people and
also the government doesn't allow people
to reduce such information hospital
doctors are scared but it cannot talk
CDC staffs are scared
I feel very disappointed but I already
know this would happen because I know
the corruption amount is kind of
international organization like taboo
issue to China common to China Communist
Party Carmen let's hope she gets a
chance to speak on CNN don't bet on it
Gordon Chang is the author of the book
the coming collapse of China can't come
too soon he joins us tonight gordon
thanks so much for coming on first the
obvious do you buy her story
I do Tucker because she talks about a
change in attitude in colleagues that in
Hong Kong as well as the people that she
was in Kanto
within China and that occurred about the
middle of January
well that is consistent but what we know
about the cover-up in China so the
timelines match up and that's really
critical so yes I do believe she's not
only compelling she's also credible so
why wouldn't she be a prominent voice in
the discussion about kovat 19 I worry
that she will not get a hearing except
on this channel
well she carries a message that you know
is going to be in discordant with what
we hear elsewhere because you know this
has become like President Trump versus
everybody else and so you have a lot of
people propagating China's narratives in
this country because it is politically
expedient for them to do so in the short
term and of course we are in a political
season but yes she says this is not an
issue of politics and it's very
important that we listen to what she
says because it does corroborate much of
what we know about what the World Health
Organization in China we're doing in
that critical January period what do you
think I mean and let me just agree with
you and fatica Lee this isn't about the
president it's not about politics it's
about public health which isn't served
when governments lie to cover their own
misdeeds or mistakes what do you think
the truth is about the origin of this
disease you know we don't know I mean
there's two main theories of course one
of them is this was a zoonotic transfer
in the wild from an animal to a human
the other is that this was an accidental
release from the Wuhan Institute of
virology and I have to say that my view
is the latter one because most diseases
in China originate and these coronavirus
diseases originated in southern China
all of a sudden we have one originating
in the middle of China within 20 miles
of China's p4 biosafety lab that is
extremely suspicious we know that a
Chinese major-general was put in charge
of the lab sometime around March and I
believe that he cleaned up the lab to
prevent the world from knowing any
evidence of what was going on
because Chinese researchers reach the
conclusion that you have reached there
is there is evidence that this happened
is anybody in the in so-called
international community working to find
the truth and working to make sure it
doesn't happen again that nothing like
this is unleashed on the world the next
time yeah what we're seeing is the World
Health Organization covering up for
China they've now got two researchers in
Beijing to prepare the way for a third
w-h-o mission to China but they're only
studying the zoonotic transfer they're
not going to Wuhan from what we can tell
they're not going to the Wuhan Institute
of virology so really this is an attempt
to bolster China's narrative which was
built I think this narrative was built
by China to really divert attention away
from what it was doing in that biosafety
lab what a tragedy if the propaganda
works as it so often does
Gordon Cheng thank you for your clarity
on that appreciate it Thank You Tucker